a man has died in Hong Kong after being
caught in clashes between pro-russian
straightest and police the 70 year old
street cleaner was hit in the head with
a brick on Wednesday it's not clear who
threw it earlier this month a student
fell from a car park and later died from
his injuries
the unrest in Hong Kong has worsened in
recent days after more than five months
of anti-government unrest
well let's cross over to Hong Kong where
our correspondent Matthias Berliner is
standing by for us but tears this is now
the second death related to the protests
within a week what more do we know about
how this particular incident happened we
know that two groups of people were
standing were confronting each other
hurling Britax at each other one of the
groups were protesters and the other
groups the other group were people who
were against the protest it is not very
clear where these people came from it
happened had a suburb of Hong Kong in
the very north near the Chinese border
whether they were from the place or
whether they had gathered there so these
two groups were hurling bricks at each
other and the street cleaner city
administration said he was a street
cleaner on his lunch break was in the
middle between these two groups and he
was hit then by a brick it is not clear
whether he belong to any of the groups
or whether he just stood in the wrong
place at the wrong time
well this brick throwing incident
clearly shows that people in Hong Kong
are divided on their views about the
protests and innocent people are getting
caught up in it the difference in
opinion in Hong Kong extends to Chinese
mainland durs living there let's take a
look
a neighborhood forum on Hong Kong's
political crisis one of many such events
that Hong Kong's vibrant civil society
has organized sociology lecturer Minnie
Lee is happy to speak out publicly
something she would have never
considered 11 years ago when she first
moved to Hong Kong from the Chinese
mainland
Torrance's inch we sell a handle at home
I suddenly heard so many different
opinions when I arrived and some of them
felt completely unacceptable even just
talking about them was too much I had a
feeling of danger I felt there were
foreign forces trying to change me or
even brainwash me then I became curious
today mini Li ardently supports free
speech when the pro-democracy movement
took to the streets in June she joined
them and when the government ignored the
demands she even went on a hunger strike
since then the protests have escalated
massively with police using tear gas and
rubber bullets and protesters hurling
petrol bombs and bricks almost daily and
things just keep getting worse many
people in Hong Kong are shocked by the
violence victim o is one of them he also
arrived in Hong Kong more than a decade
ago he works in the financial sector and
proudly identifies as a Hong Kong Hong
Kong people must condemn the violence
and the illegal acts no matter where we
are from including our friends from
Germany the US Japan we all need to
stand up and say no to this this must
stop
but he's not concerned about the city's
freedoms to those who say they fear that
Hong Kong might become more and more
like the mainland he responds so what
was a 1991 so see somehow I'm from
Nanjing I know nanjing very well I often
go to Shanghai and to Beijing I don't
know how I'm Kong very well I think
there's nothing to fear
I think the source of this fear is that
people don't understand the mainland
polio G mini Li however is afraid of
losing her freedoms videos which he
publicly defends the democracy movement
are circulating online when her father
recently texted her from the mainland
warning that what she said was
inappropriate she knew who was behind it
my father doesn't know how to bypass the
Great Firewall there's no way he came
across my speeches on the sense of
Chinese internet I didn't tell him so
the only way he could have known is that
state security told him so I asked him
where the agents had visited him he
didn't reply mini Li hasn't been
intimidated by the threats so far she is
still speaking out hoping to preserve
her hard-won freedoms but yes as we just
saw there in your report the mainland
Chinese living in Hong Kong also have
different views about the protests is it
possible to generalize about Hong
Kongers how Hong Kong is in general
regard mainland Chinese in their midst
well in the last few years there has
been a lot of concern about immigration
from China there is a quota for new
immigrants and a lot of the localist
politicians have seen this quota as too
high they see it as a deliberate policy
to make the city more mainland ish this
has not been at the focus of these
protests however these protests are
about something else and it depends a
lot on more on the opinion I would say
than on the identity or for example the
language that people use if you go to a
protest and you speak Mandarin you are
probably going to be met with more
suspicion than if you speak Cantonese
and the opponents of the protest those
who are pro-government
are met with slogans saying go back to
the mainland or say there
is suspicion but if people integrate
well into Hong Kong or if they endorse
protests or if they come and they voice
support for the protest they met also
quite well with the by the protesters so
it depends a lot on the stance and on
how the people how the people react but
it there is it is a topic that has been
discussed a lot in this city what about
support for the protest movement in
general mattias are there any opinion
polls that show us where Hong Kongers
stand in relation to the protests yeah
there are there are survey's about the
general opinion and they are they were
regularly conducted we see we have seen
so far a very stable divide that is
about I would say 3/4 to 1/4 or 2/3 to
1/3 depending on what particular
question they ask in these surveys and
the escalation until recently has not
changed this this pattern it is it
depends of course when it comes to
violence it does not mean that all those
who support the the protests also
support the violent actions but 2/3
about seem to blame the police more for
the escalation than the protesters these
is they this is data from October though
there the new poll from November is not
out yet we do not know how the recent
events in the recent days that were a
serious escalation have changed this
pattern but he is thank you very much
for bringing some date in w's Matthias
Berliner in Hong Kong